okay should be live in one moment or
maybe even now but it doesn't say that I
am yet so I'm just waiting you alive my
hell I just stop this on here
okay I have been waiting for this game
for quite a while since I when did I
hear about this I think I heard about
this game much me actually wasn't that
member I heard about it over the summer
but it feels like a while because I've
been waiting for more psychological
horror games I'm kind of done with all
these horror games that just jumps cut
jump straight jump scare like leave you
in the dog just so done with it so
visage was great and Call of Cthulhu
it's been said so many ways apparently
it's um is it one syllable cool or two
syllables cool nothing that's supposed
to be two syllables anyway so if you are
a fan of horror literature you might
have come across a little dude called HP
Lovecraft and he wrote the Call of
Cthulhu
Cthulhu Cthulhu is how most people say
it but he's supposed to kind of like
choke Outland that's what like the story
said anyway um he won't know it's I've
kind of like short fantasy stories but
what was great about what they weren't
really fun to see they were more like
horror fantasy I guess um so fight but
he wrote called Cthulhu and people some
people think it's true
because he wrote it in a very
interesting manner and it was kind of
talking about alternate dimensions and
gods but not the kite not the type of
gods that we know and that we worship
today it's like they're not even evil ah
he represented evil in a completely
different way because it's not so much
so that evil they don't exactly have bad
intentions
they just legit don't care like we are
the dirt on the bottom of a god shoe you
know like when you have a fly in your
house you don't necessarily mean to ruin
their life when you're whacking them out
the window but they're annoying you
though in your way that is what we are
to the great Cthulhu so anyway enough
rambling this game looks super
interesting because it takes everything
from Lovecraft stories and his way of
telling the narrative because the
narrative it's usually a bit ambiguous
it's all about fear of the unknown so it
leaves a lot of details down to you guys
down to the reader down to our
imagination which really is a great
scare tactic because as you know with
anything Liam neva and stuff like that
as soon as you see the monster it's not
as scary anymore but Lovecraft was all
about giving us little detail as
possible as little explanation as
possible to leave you shrouded in
mystery and darkness and that made
things ten times scarier can you tell I
wrote my dissertation partly on enough
craft so oh thanks you like my lipstick
Thank You Emma toast it's actually
Geoffrey stock anyway um yeah that's
carrot let's do this I'm freaking
excited to see what the games like it's
supposed to have this madness mechanic
that changes and adapts to the way that
you play the game so if you like hide
too much from the jump scares and you
start to become mad and one of the big
ins over the begins the biggest selling
points for me on the game was that
you don't know if things are entirely
wheel which is perfect it's just it's
very Lovecraftian man so you might see
something you might see like a spooky
shadow or like some water rippling but
you don't know if that's your insanity
or if that's reality let's play enough
rambling okay hello Michael hello Emma
toes hello touch nirvana I love a bit of
Nirvana in here hello brony stars gaming
oh and you like prefetching thank you
thank you so much and hey disturbia so
let's go play the game let me know if
like the game volume is too low or too
loud I'm too low or too loud just like
let me know give me a shower and I can
change it around no biggie
it's a no biggie okay
dude where's there you up were you wet
there you wet okay and now I haven't
played the old the old called Cthulhu
game okay
empty sock please Boston 1924 add
repairs veteran at the first world war
downs his maruzen liquor and sleeping
pills he is now our private detective
who has trouble finding a case able to
lift him from his torpor PS must find a
new case quickly or risk losing his
license ah you got drinking problems as
well which is not gonna help the sanity
into the madness let's enter what come
on dude I'm pressing enter or I'm
clicking don't hit again it keeps like
toggling off right here what am i doing
everything is gone now may the gods pity
the man who in his callousness can
remain sane to the hideous end
[Music]
waking up with sharks that's completely
normal
why not
[Music]
my game it's saved already oh ok so
moving ones like this game kind of went
crazy and then everything just went off
the screen so that was perfect so I
can't see anything
um but you guys ok you can see it oh
yeah ok yeah I'm still alive nice
just had to check sorry
[Music]
it's very sensitive it might have to
change that we'll see
[Music]
okay I didn't expect this I thought we
were gonna start in office like it not
little detective office
but I'm not complaining I mean get to
the spook straight away that's fine okay
I'm used to shift for crouch
I don't shift for Brian probably one
so I can't go here this probably it's a
cinematic Crouch that's probably
somewhere ah yeah
[Music]
was that
you must light up some some items in
order to interact okay well let go
got a little lamp here
[Music]
can I get on the boat
[Music]
okay nope cannot get on the boat
[Music]
so I can use my clippers
is that Cthulhu
whatever helps me to marry more yeah no
I agree
[Music]
before you of the true church chosen for
water
wait am i the offering or was it the
shark good lesson over the shock
[Music]
[Music]
it's Baltimore attempted to change me
Nestor's there he is
very tiny
[Music]
so what were here were they there were
the order I need to read it again
they were the order of something
basically there it's like a kind of a
religion more like a cult that's based
around Cthulhu but they he speaks to
them within ruin through it through in
their dreams he speaks to them so that's
why I was dreaming which which makes
sense
[Music]
I used to be an avid reader with agency
doesn't attract top-notch cases
I'm so jealous for everyone playing
redhead but I'm playing this married
woman runs off with her girlfriend
husband couldn't understand
okay so this is like one of his previous
cases Natural Sciences mystics
archaeology now it'll be bored I'm
listening that's correct is that
[Music]
ah so these are like my personality
traits quite strong already vestigation
represents your investigating talents
well it's quite talented already mm-hmm
sport he represents ability to find
hidden objects eloquence could keep do
better in that need more medical
knowledge and occultism my knowledge of
the occult sciences is science the
science guys as science the science
psychology human behavior no chance of
understanding motivations of a person
today I'm going to use an origin of
artifacts drugs dolls
analyzing scenes okay cool
oh wait sure you sir
nope what am i doing why am i oh how
many ever got oh I've got four remaining
points so yes that's up these then I
don't wanna
let's do psychology cuz that's fun
wait I wanted to G
Oh Oh I've only got 5% occultism I'm
like I knew nothing about the occult
I've got one more left
yeah I wish I use it on
mmm I don't know who's that one played
the game yeah like I don't know what I'm
lacking in what do you think guys
hey Albert hey Cristobal
hey Michael hey Jackson shut
it's a remake of the old one I don't
know cuz I never play the old one so I'm
sorry you can't fly yeah from what I
hear though it is kind of similar to the
old one always like it's taken aspects
of the old one people are excited about
it you played the old one sir
yeah I don't know I don't know I'm
thinking it should be one of these guys
they may be medicine or eloquence
eloquence correct
okay let's do that validate yes what's
wrong
you've been accepting fewer new cases
work is scarce but all those cases worth
I'm coming
so I came here on the advice of a person
whom I hold in high esteem and I must
say that I expected anything but a
drunkards lair you're free to leave
anytime sir do you know to whom you
speak
stephen webster industrialist and art
collector all of Boston lousy tell me
mr. Pierce are you capable of handling a
new case or are you simply a deadbeat
inebriate have you come to me
it means you're Desmond nobody believes
me they take me for an old fool Sarah my
little girl she is dead even you must
know her she was Sarah Hawkins the
painter yes the police accuse her of
killing her family they all died in a
fire Sarah her husband and Simon my
grandson I can't do anything for a woman
I was already dead find out the truth
they say she was mad but I know that's a
lie she would never have done such a
thing
but if you have no proof I've brought
all that I have look I want you to look
carefully at this painting tell me all
the assumptions that come round alright
let's get our investigation on you
Freddy Krueger what am I supposed to
find tell me tell me if this is the work
of madness or if on the contrary you
managed to detect some logic a
rationality to follow so that I may
understand it is that all you want from
me yes please
all right I'll look at you
that's all you've got a painting I
placed a file on your desk it contains
everything I have on the affair let's
see you have details press jj4 journal
that makes sense but I'll probably
forget that so if you could remember it
and tell me later on when I forget
that'd be great
Hey look ours says the doctor came well
repeats me that I no longer need my
remedy yeah to keep my memories at bay
but I know that if I stop the memories
will return okay so he drinks because he
keeps having his memories which are what
dreams about a strange picture painted
by Sarah hoping it's a best short while
after before her tragic death was sent
to her father just after the artist died
he has convinced that she is a cinder he
brought me the painting so his element
so Stephen Webster the wealthy
industrialist came to my office we have
reopened the Sara Hallman's case okay
cool well let's examine the stuffs
a warehouse on dark water some sketches
of the Hawkins family rather thin a
shipping label some of its unreadable
but I can make out part of the address
warehouse re6 dark water
the police support says the fire started
in the dining room reclaim the whole
family the police and then the whole
family the police decide on a domestic
accident but they nevertheless in system
Sarah hope unisys we mental frailty why
pressed getting an article written about
the marriage of Sarah and Charles
Hawkins a businessman from the Ireland
of dark water they live a reclusive and
hopeless life
okay
well that doesn't really give me
anything guys does that nope
yes
listen it's as if Sarah Hawkins breathed
a message into it so mr. Pierce what do
you make of these elements
it's she was bloody mad me I don't know
um you shouldn't take this painting like
me find out about warehouse 36 well yeah
that would be a good one
I read about her mental fragility in the
police support something's not right
with this story which would we choose
what do you think hey Alex
and rural
the game's literally just start guys so
I don't know I love that you can say
whether it's worth playing or not
because I literally just started playing
it fine uh whoosh I I need to find out
more yeah yeah something's not right
with her her husband was a big deal on
the island police are sticking to the
accident theory though they mentioned
Sarah's mental state was fragile I
believe you are right sir this case is
not as simple as it is I am aware of
that I believe there is more to this
case than just an accident
mmhmm yeah
hmm okay Alex since we do the painting
one I shall do for you the meaning could
be exactly as it appears I think your
daughter is sending you a message
that's what I believe too it was three
months ago that I received the call from
the police telling me of my daughter's
death and yet a short while after this
painting was delivered to my home
the painting is linked to this case
can't you see you must find the meaning
behind all this
okeydoke I shall try um you must tell me
if what the police suggest about the
mental state of your daughter is true no
Sarah had visions everyone knew that she
never would have heard a fly
she only thought she saw things saw
things I never knew what she meant by
that
my daughter was an enigmatic figure mr.
Pierce you must find out the truth about
her life and death
the sender's label mentions warehouse 36
that's right
it came with Sarah's last painting and
you think your daughter could have been
the sender that is what you must find
out go to dark water find warehouse 36
never heard of that place
where is that it's a small remote island
off the coast of Boston ah okay I
suppose you want to ship me off there
dark water holds the secret regarding my
daughter and all the trailers like he's
in this tiny town and I'm guessing that
this is why he's in the tiny town so
yeah great
you understand I'm willing to do
anything for my daughter to recover her
honor quiet down I'm on your side let's
sum things up an artist lives with her
family in a house fire your only clue is
a sort of premonitory painting sent from
dark water right before her death
correct and the rumors about her
supposed falling which you don't totally
deny find that warehouse find out the
truth regarding Sarah Hawkins death you
will be handsomely compensated alright
I'll take the case
I'll go to dark water Thank You mr.
Pierce I didn't expect any less coming
from a man in your situation do mana I
am have a choice
dark water I think I've got a book on
the North Atlantic well no doubt find
some information on this island in there
I used to be an avid reader
the learning of medicine well this isn't
the book that he was looking for though
but it's gonna up my like medicine
points well that's good
why is it for that yeah it up she is as
well
what other I wonder why I still take
these things the doctors prescribed him
when I were champion of wall all seems a
war veteran as well so I guess that's
why he thinks he has his dreams but now
if he could do new um for a while that
effects been wearing else
let's have a cheese wheel dream no no no
no no what do you think that is whiskey
Natural Sciences linguistics like you
dark waters off the cruise Boston but
I've never heard of it according to this
book it was often mentioned during whale
hunting times at the end of the 19th
century but it seems to have been shown
since then whales Doug Florida Islands
has been in him in inhabited since the
14th century and is still rich with the
many memories left by his Lost Tribes
that sounds like a way to get premise
for a ghostly horror game doesn't it but
don't let the romanticism of these
moving evidences of such naive and
primitive beliefs for you into
forgetting how violent their gods were
the gods a gigantic creature still on
its the walls of long abandoned caves
was it a sea or a dream god no one knows
but today's inhabitants the sons and
daughters of the proud whale hunters
still remember the mysterious and
tumultuous story of their small land on
the coast of Massachusetts ok so are
these like the the occult that praised
all I have to do is go to the port I
just hope that I can find a boat able to
take me to dark water a good old story
of blackmail in a speakeasy
Barney Harvey didn't like the way I
closed this one but when you're already
outside the law
okay I think that's everything
I should get rid of all this stuff
all right time to go
car horn and horses because it's bass
like back in the day I'm guessing is
just old cars and still horse-drawn
carriages outside hey Becca me hey Jacob
all
okay so let's find out if this woman
Sarah did actually kill her family in
the house fire or something else
something more sinister is going on
which probably is that one don't know
why but the game is here we go
[Music]
focus Home Interactive prisons
[Music]
a game by cyanide studio
[Music]
almost there
[Music]
it's not like sharp rocks I guess go
cela
[Music]
the Mojo of you guys have all seen the
trailers and stuff but I just remember
him walking around and there was a big
dead whale so maybe we'll say that learn
I don't know stay on board there's guys
coming to unload
welcome to Dark Water Island mr. ps1
thank you
so what wind brought you an
investigator's the Hawking's case mean
anything to you
I said Charles Hopkins may have been a
landlubber
and his wife Sarah Hawkins a nice young
woman and a great pain
oh there it is you know what I'll go
have a drink of a stranded whale what
you need is a good pick-me-up Mitchell
may not be very welcoming but his bar
holds a surprise for you as for me
you'll find me at the harbormaster's
office if it's the Hawkins family that
brings you here I have a pile of
documents that should interest you
understood I'm going for a look around
the docks Thanks
hey mother theorem and CD
so these are all whale catches anyway so
I guess that makes sense although it's
still pretty morbid hey Sullivan can't
go any faster
the blood is just beginning to coagulate
it died a short time ago only a
specialist okay so every time if I have
more medical knowledge you would know
more it's a sign that's the same goes
for you sir
move along don't treat me another one
you're completely overwhelmed and you
could do with reinforcements what do you
think you that you can call the National
Guard to an island like dark warning for
a stranded fish gosh-darn mister not
like another one of these locals go give
you a valuable advice somewhere else huh
now please allow me to do my job
wait I'm not done with you sir see that
I'm busy can't you you can't no you see
that I'm busy can't you what could have
done so much damage
oh yeah trouble something real bad why
are you looking at me like that
don't put that beast back in the water
you shyster you're crazy
what happened cops they can't understand
ok so it's no way I'm gonna get over
that instead let's have a little look
around here
Oh Jackson Jack I really want to go see
the new Halloween movie I don't have
anyone to go see with her should I throw
my own I'm too scared to go wait you're
that dude that was over here now you're
over here where'd you come from why are
you walking oh okay oh okay leave me
alone so the people around here are
lovely they really make you feel very
welcome I'm so glad I came
um let's go get a beer prohibition is
just a joke around here that suits me
fine
oh look I have a London don't want to
pick it up yet I mean it's just randomly
now I'm guessing over there from for
later something will happen later
let's go Gabey em
[Music]
hey be careful you shoot him Sir
and he caught her ID let's get him
another drink he's dry in my bar we
don't serve troublemakers my strength is
pretty good why not I know I hate
choices yeah you deserve this man and
you can't say he's been on his best
behavior he's a regular it was you who
provoked him by turning up with your
mainland manner you mistake my manner
I asked nothing more than to become a
regular as well which will be difficult
if you refuse to serve me yeah all of
your less talkative when you're drunk
try me we'll see
[Music]
what can you tell me about it
we all knew she was famous on the maize
it ha he didn't even say the name never
understood why then I don't want to
speak ill of the dead yeah so speaking
ill if it's true that's true her vision
was it so terrible way I see the truth
is really a question a point of view
what do you mean by that do you still
trust the truth after a bottle of
whiskey her style made her famous how
would you describe it tortured yeah well
it wasn't normal
I mean for a young woman with a child
and all that we saw them in the papers
and we said to ourselves who can paint
such things is that how she sees the
world so they made you feel
uncomfortable to see themselves make up
your own mind
but I guess yeah we've only seen one
paintings I've got what I need anything
else yes why the whale what's extremely
well I guess this bar has been here a
long time well can I tell you I'm a
nostalgic sort of guy
the name reminds us of the Golden Age of
dock water when our Wailers left four
long months and came back sweating and
stinking of the oil and flesh of the
whales they'd been hot it was a tough
time all the same but steeped in glory
we've never known such wealth since then
okay let's ask about warehouse do you
know where this places warehouse 36 dark
water Harbor the Hawkins warehouse I see
yeah if I were you I wouldn't hang
around there why not
first off there are rumors sailors from
around here say you can hear noises
coming from the warehouse at night
screams that's greens and that's not all
there's the fate of its owners and all
the superstitions that go with it but
I'll say no more anything else I didn't
expect to find alcohol on this island
what's the source of this miracle you
mean who our source of supply wouldn't
like me to betray them to the first
comer
I'll tell nobody she'd know it anyway
anything else um I shouldn't really
drink but why not I mean you have to
physically told me about a little
pick-me-up you want a drink
try this
I think we'll get along well
cool it's at the end this will affect
your destiny Oh way I had attempted buy
the goods
did I already find out about what can
you tell me who else
we all knew she was famous on the
mainland for her paintings never
understood why then I don't want to
speak ill oh I've got what I need
anything else no I'm good thank you
leave that'll be all for now
sorry about being rude to you oh you
like our song we're two sirens we may
not be pros but we give it all we've got
that's true it's a reminder of the time
when we were still fishing for whales
off Darkwater Island
what brought whaling to an end the
whales of course they all disappeared
you exhausted the stocks you could say
that yes there were fewer and fewer of
them until the last the biggest one of
the miraculous cats exactly what I've
never heard this song before only people
from here know it it tells the story of
the miraculous cats that's a local
legend watch what you say young man that
cat saved our island where's the proof
where'd that prove without it the whole
of dark water would have died of hunger
in 1847 it's true
everything happens else paper report
what report the one that's framed right
behind you our grandparents tasted its
flesh dang it was delicious I bid you
farewell Jim goodnight stranger so long
[Music]
this is like a crazy mad scientist
nightmares can hear things and voices
whispering well if like me its reader
and appear at various locations gifted
with its own consciousness until it
finds a new reader
[Music]
ah that's it maybe we should let him
take it no no the risks are too high so
enjoy pure knowledge never look at what
the miraculous catch apparently the most
significant event of the last 80 years
we had given up hope the crew of the
cilia of the Silla also that was the
boat that he was just on or what remains
of it return to dark for support late on
Tuesday afternoon the locals immediately
rushed to the docks to welcome the last
whaling ship from the Ireland people
weren't amazed at the sight of the
unbelievable coach the brave vessel had
on board of a size that went beyond that
of the formidable toothed whales this
set a scene that it's already being
called America's catch covered the whole
deck and parts of it were hanging over
the side of the ship the surviving
sailors told a frightening account of
their perilous catch but also of its
meats unmatched in its quality and
plentiful nutrias benefits there was no
doubt of the immense size of the whale
will allow numerous inhabitants of dark
waters to feed themselves bringing an
end to the famine from which part of the
island was suffering where husband went
I was just the warehouse I'm looking for
as well mr. marks is putting his
warehouse up for rent for the June for
fishing workshop for storage activities
you can contact him so that happened
around the same time as the mirror
miraculous catch maybe that has a has a
point special evening it is trying to
ground celebrate the return of our brave
brothers all the staff invite you to
accept your free tasting event eat eat
the whale okay okay so yes that's a clue
I'd say
[Music]
Asylum staff hi sorry I wasn't
eavesdropping I leave that woman no no
the woman obviously hey Yaga muffin hey
booty Nina hey Brett hey Gabrielle and
hey patty Vera's what you looking at
stranger oh yeah no look at all of her
empty glasses I've rarely seen a were so
confident the sexes judge me it was a
compliment
so was let me drink stranger I told you
to beat it
Oh bowls I forgot that you can't just go
through all the conversation if you pick
the wrong one then you can't ah keep
freaking doing that right I need to like
get it in my mindset choose the right
one cuz you might not have a chance to
go through all the conversation strands
and I'm a freaking idiot
no she just thinks I'm a sexist pig um
okay let's go out the back way
no okay
okay
I wonder if she was the gal doctor now
these two obvious is really around here
nothing why is there that random
stranded ship out there I guess I just
can't do anything about it
okay here you are
hello where these documents roll out the
Charles Hawkins cargo manifests they're
on the table next to you but in truth
you're likely to be disappointed when
you're done come join me on the deck
okay so on the table next to me well
which one oh here
these manifests are signed by Charles
Hawkins that's all I get from them only
a few days is still legible 1819 1907
and a partial date the rest of the
document is blacked out who would want
this information to be hidden
when she first does fishing equipment
huh could do with some rust remover Oh
gorgeous found the toilet perfect
exactly what I needed right Oh wailing
sperm whales a souvenir from the more I
was when us through with whales
I guess this blackboard hasn't been
wiped for more than 70 years a Silla it
finished up beached at the entrance to
the harbor upstairs is the totally
blocked
hey nice does this mean that my
medicines gone up now yeah oh it doesn't
go quite that much so goes up my leg
little bit but I'm nearly on number 2
level 2 to CP so some bad
cool I think I can still I can still
remove them from bits by wanting to have
more interesting right to be fair I
don't actually understand how the
conversation ones are working do they
give you more conversation strands I
thought that they would give you kind of
like clues as to how people would take
your conversation a cow it would be seen
but that doesn't seem to be the case
book we'll see
I'm having some issues with the game
kind of glitching and just minimizing
Brandon me this man and Fitz why it
could be twins
well the Fitzroy doesn't have a peg leg
does he
oh the other one what a macabre suit
oh that's the peg leg okay
haven't played a detective game and so
long last one I played was like this
Jack the Ripper detective game when I
exposed to 60 and it's a pretty good oh
I did play in LA tomorrow as well that's
quite fun so a little bit
I wonder what captain Fitzroy has got to
say about this woman Cat Cat gherkin
she's the one from the bar the one who
didn't drink what's his game belt dude
oh yes it's about dunno basically where
we are detective we're on Dark Horse's
that's right
we're basically doing doing a detective
job there's a woman who burnt down in a
warehouse with her family
ah she was in the warehouse walk she
brought down with her family but they
thought that she did it and she draws
like some rubbish paintings so everyone
thinks that she was like a little bit
crazy but we don't think that she did so
we're trying to find some clues to see
that she didn't however we're already
having like visions and hallucinations
about Cthulhu but he thinks that it's
because he was a war veteran and he
takes like so you can feel me he drinks
a lot we have a drinking problem so
that's the gist yeah okay the terms of
our agreement are clear keep your men
under control you cannot afford to
provoke us no need to answer this
message just make your payment to the
carry on broken this place seems half
abandoned yeah
where is he
I am from here I see everything that
goes on in the harbour the hard-working
lives of my sailors the fights of the
stranded whale even the antics of these
Wharf rats don't escape me it's you who
lays down the law around here oh I
wouldn't go that far
I'm just the last serving captain on
dock water tell me what I can do to help
you manifests have been blacked out
they're totally unreadable yeah I saw
that I've got no idea who did it or why
I don't remember having count assigned
anything special enough for someone to
hide it and why obliterate the dates as
well as the goods stored in the
warehouse you mean that the dates have
some meaning
maybe these are because I've upped my
conversational skills so I've a lot
certain answers
I'm surprised Charles Hawkins had goods
to store
knowing that whaling stopped in 1847 I
see that you are interested in the
history of our island indeed maritime
activities ceased altogether at the end
of the last century I imagine that the
Hawkins family had other types of
contracts but you don't know with whom
you know there was none of my business
I'm looking for warehouse 36 do you know
where it is
look it's right there the warehouse
opposite the massive building of course
but I can't get past that finish rail
you know who the building belongs to
don't you I'm not gonna lie there's an
important line
it belonged to the Hawkinsville you
under arrest I'm sorry that ship owners
from father to son I think that somebody
here wanted me to search this warehouse
it's like down a quarter
oh yeah I was looking at your a
photograph one of the man in front of
the boat ah yes I could see the one
you're talking about
interesting resemblance I thought it was
you but with a wooden leg brother dad
that's my father in the photograph your
father John Fitzroy captain of the Silla
his wooden leg is here you can go and
see if you're interested already have
I'm not interested in seeing it again
Thanks yeah I found a threatening letter
signed by a certain cat what
I don't mind you visiting my
harbormaster's office but I prefer if
you didn't go through my affairs are you
being black thing not exactly know that
shyster wants to make us pay protection
money with any success yeah I wouldn't
say that but she terrifies my men as
much as her own can you not do anything
to stop her don't you worry about that
okay I'll let you deal with cat then I'm
just back from the wharves the dead
killer whale is unsettling the sailors
ah yes us men of a sea are superstitious
folk
yeah once killed it what are they yeah
we don't have many known predators
that's true
and normally they're not found around
here but then you're gonna take me for a
fool give it a try have you heard about
the depths trenches that plunge it to
the earth and the shelter creatures
unlike any other you're talking about
mythology indeed you're right the police
took the decision to put the killer
whale back into the sea you've got to
understand them they didn't know what to
do with it I think that was a mistake
who says that whatever caused those
wounds is no longer in these waters you
think we should have kept it to look
into the real cause of its death at
least
yeah I agree the miraculous catch is at
a local legend not at all
it's an episode from our glorious past
they'll read the story of the sailors
returned to dark water I already have a
wall of the stranded wait no no yeah
I've already I brought here and if you
read would win right yeah yeah great
thank you for your information you've
actually been very helpful I appreciate
I still be on my way
so come back and see me when you've got
something new
right so how are we gonna how are we
gonna do this see if we can talk to this
man I haven't tried this guy hello never
mind you're just pushing cool what
should we do okay now let's run a push
it Oh were they doing that before I
can't remember all the people are gone
okay then hello that's you you're you're
the guy right you saw what happened with
those sailors don't hang around here
unless you want trouble with the
bootleggers
I've seen the kind of messages there Bob
sends you're not scared of her of course
I am everyone's scared of that woman
she's not interested in small fry like
me you on the other hand knows around
too much you'll have dealings with her
okay so this Stephanie is not the girl
from the bar
this warehouse looks abandoned why does
it interest them so much no doubt a
question of territory but I ain't asking
you want to know more go ask the captain
good thank you I shall take my leave
the spot hidden skill allows you to
sense items it looks like there's a way
in under this great
how do I use the spot hidden skill did
anyone see didn't like tell me how it's
flashing down there but I don't know how
to use it cue
[Music]
Oh
oh wait what was that I just did
something whoo-hoo I have a lighter okay
um scroller some later my old lighter
that I engraved in the memory the 7th
7th Infantry Division
mental trauma
force the whole earth position for
several days to run away bodies and
fallen comrades about food or medical
supplies the soldiers for incidents lost
by their fellow countrymen Pierce's
traumatized by these events okay so
that's why I'd keep having those
yeah I said I don't know how to use my
little hidden clues thing
but I can go up here
I could use this old winch to lift the
grating but it's been completely taken
to bits there must be some spare parts
amid all this clutter
[Music]
okay use
oh here again
this partner was heavy loads were lifted
a ratchet device exactly what I need
this handle will be perfect for the
winch is that all I need
I did it today
[Music]
a whale vertebra if the newspaper
clipping and the bar is true this bone
is a real fossil okay
I'm free that's all we need
hey JC
Hondo ratchet device Oh No read more
what if then
what is the hidden spot hidden so if we
like on take some stuff away from like
gee no
and then give it to you can do spore
hidden here and that should help us know
sure rounding whatever
right yeah that works
but I find that green flashing things
I'm pretty sure those there is like a
button to this that I just missed
I'm just pressing all of them didn't you
did did de boop nope it's my journal
did it okay maybe no maybe I was wrong
fools what were the bloody house it
hey JC thanks for the shoutout of
perfection in your latest podcast I'm
actually thinking I'm just gonna give
all this just to make sure I haven't
[ __ ] like have I miss something I'm
just gonna use my brain can't believe
look see right
was it going to hidden hidden SWAT
something
I don't know it's just giving me stuff
for the old game cuz home ec this game
only came out like yesterday
damn oh well whatever let's just leave
and because we got some extra
information about the other from this
dude
oh this is different Hey
with no longer at home on our own island
calm down
it's not worth the effort I told that
flunky you'll see what a real sailor has
in his belly if you continue like that
everyone will see what you've got in
your belly I hope so I hope they don't
forget the lesson me
I'm not scared so girl I mean they're
going to cut you open you idiot calm
down
okay so this girl's really got people
riled up I can go that way now do ya
think I haven't opened up one another
conversation stronger did you look back
again
what can I do for you
apparently the bootleggers don't want
anyone hanging around the warehouses
they're part of the private property I
mentioned earlier and yet the place
looks abandoned
why guard the entrance as a precaution I
suppose all the warehouses are more or
less interconnected by old sewers you
mean that there's a way to go from one
to the other by tunnel I couldn't tell
you if it's still on the island
but I think I can imagine what you've
got in mind you can always visit them if
you're not the claustrophobic type so
that's one major part of this game you
develop like fears like claustrophobia
and stuff like that it's a song can I so
- you can see that I'm busy can't you
you can't understand don't put that
beast back in the water safe aye
what could have done so much damage
if I go here I'm just gonna be where do
you think you I go he won't let means
the warehouse I'm not here to hinder
your work officer Edward Pierce private
detective sorry we're all a little on
edge today what are you doing here I'm
investigating the death of the Hulk and
his family darn it
why do you want to drag up all that
stuff again my investigation has led me
to this warehouse that case was closed
months ago
hey Demian what do you know well what
more can you say about the death of the
Hawkins family not much more than what
everyone knows I wasn't on the case they
were all burnt to death
right up at their place the whole
mansion went up in flames don't get it
into your head to go wandering around up
there it's dangerous what do you mean by
that the only one left there is old
Silas and the accident is affected him
badly he can be unpredictable especially
if a stranger starts poking around the
property is he a danger to the public no
he's in his own home
do yourself a favor leave him well alone
you again I told you to beat it need to
get worked up don't these people so
freakin worried right
hmm okay so they're the ones guarding it
so they're not gonna be friendly
I didn't crawl in here though right no
idea Oh what's with you wandering around
here like a hungry dog I've got to enter
the Hawkins warehouse I guess it's gonna
be complicated
no it's very simple in fact [ __ ] off I
don't give a damn about your racket I
just want to get into this warehouse now
we don't give a damn about you there's
nothing you can do for me
yeah she's your boss what you listen
through keyholes no I read the boss yeah
she says who goes in or not shut up you
Tommy we wanted to know that you also
talk too much she must be quite
intimidating if she can make two men
like you tremble huh
she redid the smile at the last one who
wanted to get in I hope you had a good
dentist no no you don't understand
she really cut him a new smile but he
only smiles with left cheek nice so who
are you
are you stupid are you doing it on
purpose everybody knows us on dock water
I've just I knew you just say we're
standing God for the owner of the site
and we let no one enter her property Kat
okay I bid you gentlemen farewell
they're not gentlemen but it's nice of
you to be kind these guys you live here
why did you do that huh we saw what you
did to Saint Brendan
yeah we'll teach you to come onto our
island of ridicule in departures for
Texas
I've never heard of this scent is it a
local belief but everyone knows st.
Brandon the Navigator he's the patron
saint of whales and whalers what
happened to the statue go see for
yourself
he's at the end of a jetty there's you
our beloved statue and then those two
bozos behind us wait now that I think
about it it's got to be them there's one
of them who's always going back and
forth to the statue that's all we need
for them good drunkard
that statue represents your local Saint
what do you mean by local exactly you
wouldn't be looking down at us like all
townspeople do no random he protected
Wailers and fishermen like us till those
[ __ ] defaced them um two guys behind
you
what are they guarding the bootleggers
scum they're protecting their territory
from whom
I wonder they really don't have a choice
anyway they're more scared of cat than
an attack by drunken sailors if only
they would kill each other
hmm get rid of the two gods can they can
they can they who does that cat who's
shaking down Captain Fitzroy oh hold on
hold on just a minute we didn't tell you
a thing nothing at all
I have an offer that could interest you
we're listening I need you to keep them
busy for a while
you sent us to take the punishment while
you go quietly about your business
what's in it for us
what happens oh there's only one thing
that'll get us to move for sure take
care of
okay okay okay I'll be back take your
time we're going nowhere okay so on the
hunt for alcohol press let's have a look
in here anything in here how could you
be dumb enough to leave the entrance to
the warehouses unguarded keep your voice
down why not go and shout at the cat
while you're at it I don't want to end
up with her little knife under my throat
it's a stiletto you idiot and with that
smell on your breth I don't give you
much chance anyway
okay so I'm guessing they're somewhat
the other entrance that we were just
looking in but we've still got to get
the rest of the stuff to open up the
hatch and there's more to have a look at
here anyways so let's carry on
I wonder if you can find maybe some junk
that will help us around here
crap
ah that's a cute
people fishin just doesn't really look
like there's gonna be many fish down in
there but I'm not gonna put hopes down
squash his dreams
a lot of seagulls
hmm
look see people's oh oh in Piplup pip
pip lock pick knock
broke it's no use
the padlock won't give none of these
will open oh so this is the statue that
was two-faced like getting angry about
doesn't have a face
st. Brendan patron saint of sailors and
travelers desecrated
I can't even say which language is
written
it's up to you
new
either we go back and look for the rest
of it oh maybe I'll go back into the
whale the stranded whale and see if we
can get a drink to go you again what can
I get you
yes
let's say I want to buy a bottle for me
choice is yours everything's on sale how
much for a bottle of whiskey $5
I guess I'm that desperate I'm not
judging you cool thank you very much
that'll be all for now she's still gonna
talk to us another break one of those
damn sailors came looking for trouble
again but he won't try again anytime
soon
wait so you said to yourself that after
such a feat you could abandon your post
yeah that's her we taught those guys a
lesson okay you would turn right after I
told you to beat it okay so that's the
scary lady that everyone is terrified of
Charles Hawkins was a heavy drinker and
a debtor interesting okay
got some alcohols let's go give it to
the guys this is interesting it's more
definitely more of a detective game than
like a horror game at the moment
see how progressive so have you got what
we asked you for yep
look what I've got
you're a good guy you totally feeding
your rancid habit I don't feel well
hey say that - why and then go through
the windows nope
okay I'm going in bye Thank You
drunkards appreciate everything yep okay
so drunk drunk Kannada a broken ladder
aha this is the way okay
let's see
I'll have to find another way to get it
it's no use
the padlock won't give well well a
little Mallove's has got lost on our
turf you're not only inquisitive you're
also stupid
what gave you the crazy idea to come
onto my turf
it's my job
[Music]
let's just not say anything
as the cat got your tongue you have come
for a fight what I've got to say won't
change it yeah you're a quick learner
yeah I decide who comes in and who stays
out and anyone who doesn't respect my
rules I punish them so your cat is your
no I don't want to start water fights
maybe we can come to an understanding
maybe or maybe not
huh I'm sure the sword fights no blow
get this joker out of here I'm getting
careless I didn't see that coming I mean
I want to get into this house
it was just a little joke okay
so he's saying that he has to deal with
her but I'm thinking
that we have to go in through the other
way I mean we can't deal with Hevesi
prohibition is just a joke that suits me
fine there's nothing to do nightmares I
mean you try Mitchell
a drink for our new friend oh I owe you
you don't know how to fight but at least
you've got guts yeah thanks
aging guts huh I've got them too but you
don't hear me whining like a pooch who's
lost its leash you didn't back down
something that I respect so understand
by that if I catch you again you'll
carry a more permanent reminder of our
encounter tell me what brings you to
dark water I don't see any reason to lie
for every choice of you Mickey it's
pretty bad but I'm saving the deaths of
the Hawkins family it's very nice of you
to tell me the truth so openly but it's
also really stupid of you you really
don't seem to know the area let me give
you a little advice if you want to
survive more than a day in this rathole
avoid talking about them to the first
people you meet
I've got a few questions about the
island I'm not here to give you
information Mitchell will tell you what
he wants to tell you I thought that I
was gonna give you like a tactical
compliment but now is that more
dangerous than having a drink with you
I'm not kidding
the old families they were here long
before us and they'll be here long after
we are gone the old families the
descendants of the first Whalers table
worship their ancestors hey Matt - hey
QWERTY fish anything you're not the
Hawking's warehouse you're out of luck
it's on my turf it's precisely for that
reason that I've come to see you are you
pulling my leg yeah what I have taken
I've seen what you're capable of and you
didn't miss me I accept the compliment
well I see you're serious to be honest
as long as it doesn't interfere with my
business I don't care you get lucky and
I'll go with you to make sure you don't
stick your nose into things that don't
concern you sounds honest to me I'm not
finished
if I do that for you if I let you onto
our turf to conduct your little affairs
you'll be indebted to me and I guarantee
that I always collect on what I'm owed
think about it I help you you'll owe me
a favor in return
do you accept
I don't think we should get into uh
needing to do favors for people so I
think I'm gonna say no hey thou art
Reaper glad you're still here
um yeah I'm not I'm not I don't think
I'm ready to pay the part as you wish
from everything we've heard she sounds a
lot worse than she's seeming but I think
she's just putting on a show I might be
back for whatever and I think maybe
hopefully the only reason why we
couldn't find the rest of the stuff in
here was because we needed to go and do
all of that
perhaps I hope because I still haven't
worked out whether there's a mechanic
that I need
okay I was like did a wall just randomly
appear I've Noah yeah how do I do this
like it comes up with a little question
mark and I don't know how maybe
I hold down maybe use my lighter
hello looking through the rubble for
anything that might be abuse hey Joe
Adams if anyone knows like whether there
is a way for me to find hidden items
because the question mark is flashing
please let me know
okay I've only looked in
I mean to be fair shouldn't there be a
shouldn't that be settings
I mean I'm not using a gamepad but shoot
running left take up her wake arch into
her shoe no I don't think there is then
hello Oh Oh keyboard the little mouse
wheel button is a light next light
interruption yeah control that's shift
okay so I'm not missing anything
previous light night
I will try these lights but I don't
think I have any other lights lean
forward
in the diary
don't make a modification to him
hello
yeah this is the only light that I've
gone
and that's what you have to make the
deal with her but everybody doesn't want
to because I found this place miss the
way in Oh No find some more stuff
it's gotta be some more stuff
[Music]
no daddy oh wow four with me
everybody just wanted that Gouda leg
everybody don't ask him like it's gotta
be here there right
surely somewhere somewhere in amongst
all this rubble
there's any of this
I've loved him I've looked in this room
like six times now
hmm
okay just a car friend thing
mrs. boat for anything
how am i today Joe I am annoyed cuz I
don't understand I go in here and it's
giving me a question mark and I'm like
what does that mean I think it just
means that something is hidden here but
I swear how are you I'm just like oh I
just uh I don't want to strike the deal
with her every day
hey Sophie
[Music]
you saw what happened with those sailors
don't hang around here unless you want
trouble with the bootleggers it's a
little late I've already met captain
Moore at least you're still here to talk
about it she must like you so with that
please do excuse me because I'd prefer
not to be seen talking with you for too
long
oh no if I don't blame you um let's go
try talking to the dude again wait
there's a guy here can I talk to you
[Music]
and see if I didn't do it these guys
yeah
you're back again what can I do for you
oh nothing I thought I could tell I say
beyond my work ha so come back and see
me when you've got something new you are
heavily living the student life right
now Joe what does that mean like
drinking making friends studying love uh
studying is like the last thing yeah I
give me one moment I'm gonna just cheat
a little bit just make sure that I
didn't miss out on this so wait secret
hidden hidden no secret
in the cool evening when everybody's
feeling kind of moving first I say no I
got some plans Watson no and then you
stop and say all right I actually don't
know love is spooky I think we might
just have to actually do that like make
thingy would you guys think oh my god
when Joe said beans or ptosis like I
love these oh because it means I'm a
singer that I really like and I thought
that you're like making a reference to
him like listening to beans on toast
anyway let's come out to the game right
guys I don't know should I
I don't know what to do you like I
really don't want to make the deal with
that Catwoman because then I owe her and
I know that I can get into the warehouse
if I just go under under there but then
I can't find the last secret item and I
just have to stop the stream already
I just don't want to I don't want to
make I don't want to make it I don't
want to make the deal sees where the
water you chose you can see that I'm
busy can't you you can and I swear I
have looked everywhere for it
by mantas are fun coding to uni
there appeared to be a catwalk in the
warehouse from across the upstairs oh
thank you so much Jake
I really appreciate the help and I'm
gonna go back back right now but what
wait wait one second I'm just gonna have
a look do I have because I'm not making
the deal with that lady
I refuse
oh my way is that No
I'll try I shall try
I can't go over here
wait but there is door
where does that lead to them
doesn't really look like there's
anything on that side anyway
I mean Alex says I think you should have
made the deal it just seems like there's
a choice here and if there's a choice
and I'd rather not make the deal but if
I have to then obviously I will I was
just like it looks like I can make a
choice and this little glowing quest
like question mark makes me think that
hey there's still something here that
I'm just too stupid to have seen
- super - not obscene that that makes
more sense
can I jump
but I can crouch
I am authority investigating come on if
there's something here I better find it
I am the ultimate okay it should be
possible to mom oh that feels so good
super cold okay at least who didn't make
the deal with the lady I am I am a happy
I am a happy yet one okay let's do it
looks like everything is in its place
just to try to turn this hand please am
strong enough broke oh okay I need to
find help to get me into the warehouse
to find something that will help me open
this
love is crazy everybody seems you like
old Halloween
can you tell mm-hmm okay where am I
gonna find the secondary objectives find
how to get you into the warehouse sir
can you help when you please I know you
leave me alone please I don't I need
some help
hmm
we're gonna use
Johanna help me
these guys don't like cap maybe they'll
help me I don't know you wanna talk to
me again
[Music]
where were you back again what can I do
for you I think I need to actually find
something but I don't know what I could
use
it sort of everything
I shall be on my way so come back and
see me when you've got something to wear
could something be to help me
broken this place seems half abandoned
broken Bell it's not gonna help me
what a macabre souvenir can I use that
what a macabre souvenir anything in the
toilet absolutely not right
Shai stirs you're crazy you can see that
I'm busy can't you you can't wait oh
yeah
Schuster's you shyster
it's no use the padlock won't give
it looked like everywhere that haven't I
surfaces hidden items around then that
question mark should appear on the
bottom left
but the macabre 7-yard it's just called
on phones yeah it is QWERTY
damns anyone have any ideas
I am I really didn't want to give in to
that woman there
do
maybe I can get these drunk people know
they won't talk to me now as I got my
own trouble great
then once me neither
you again I told you to beat it no need
to get worked up
where am I can I find some help
that's no way to treat an omen oh yeah
he's gonna get us into trouble
you can't understand you're not sailors
it's a sign there's something coming
something real bad
don't put that beast
maybe there's something on the boat
you
can I go under here
it's not looking good guys
what are these merry men you liked our
song we're two sirens to new you house
we may not be bows but we give it all
we've got
that's true it's a reminder of the time
when we were still fishing for weight I
know I heard the Hawkins family owned a
warehouse on the docks an old family of
ship owners tell me something I don't
already know they were made much richer
by the miraculous catch you shouldn't
talk about that dad like that we're not
speaking ill we're just saying that
Daniel Dawkins made a fortune without
taking any risk there it's speaking al
you say it's your proof that the
miraculous catch really did happen
wait heard the hotheads family owned a
warehouse on the docks an old family
yeah they were made much richer by two
shouldn't talk up we're not speaking ill
they're just saying that Daniel oh yes
it's your okay you're not your okay nice
not helping
[Music]
you help me that's it maybe we should
let him take so bringing you but no too
high it's a book after all you again
what can I get you I don't know it like
a crowbar something what do you know
about the Hawkins warehouse if I were
you I wouldn't hang around there why not
first off there were rumors sailors from
around here say you can hear noises
coming from the warehouse at night
screams that sort of thing screams and
that's about all anything it
what can you tell me about it
we all lose shoes Finn I've got what I
need anything
Charles Hawkins owed you a lot of money
do you know if he had problems I don't
know the details and it's not my
business money or not he was always
welcome in my BA the Hawkins family was
always much appreciated on the island
I read the article in the miraculous
catch interesting local folklore don't
get it into your head to repeat that
round here on that day the crew of this
biggest way I'll ever caught
exceptionally not water from a fan I
know I know
no I don't want another drink okay
that'll be all for now
I'm still not gonna say yes
an it you'll see it a drink for our no
you sure huh you didn't want to tell me
I'm investigating Ferran but it's all
sigh make it if you want away should've
lied no I won't bother my face okay
where am I gonna find something to help
me with this
like maybe my stats just weren't high
enough maybe that's why which is
annoying
I can't remove any now
No
[Music]
hey Pablo
hey Adonis Oh Jake says I should just
talk to cat but I don't want to take the
offer it says I can find something to
get me into the warehouse find help to
get you oh wait unless that is cat Oh
fine
damnit hey Mitchell a drink for our new
friend I owe you you don't know how to
fetch it huh understand I'm I'm fastened
yeah you reek of private I will Hawkins
now why doesn't that surprise me if you
want to survive more than a day in this
rathole
I know you want to tell me I need to the
halkan you're out of luck it's precisely
for that reason are you pulling my thing
kiddo I've seen and you do I accept well
to be honest but I'll go we found almost
I'm not if I do that you'll be indebted
and I Gareth ink about it shall I
I have to I have to we always have one
detective follow me
nobody questions I wasn't strong enough
to believe that Fitzroy stood up to him
that dope tried to save face in front of
his sailors they Revere their brave
captain as they do their old statues but
sooner or later all statues get buried
in bird [ __ ] and nobody cares and the
police they do nothing to stop you the
local cops the cops drink like everyone
else sweetheart they know where their
interests lie apart from that pigheaded
Bradley I don't know whether to so she
brings him I'll go and then she gets
control over like everything alcohol is
the source of everything
Thanks I'm going in it's fine he's with
me
oh okay
it's quite interesting though there is
like the intimidating boss characters
quite a young female hello who is not
afraid to kick you in the balls so yeah
can you hurry up on fruity impatient
why is she picking her boss do you not
have it you know I still need to hold
your hand or do you think you'll get by
on your own now don't overdo it
good in that case I'll leave you I've
done enough mothering for now
oh this place stinks
what is the connection between this
place and the cell hockey salsa house oh
gosh oh my gosh oh we construction
these painkillers were prescribed three
months ago someone has been taking them
since the time of the Hogan's death it
smells as bad as it looks
can't sleep I know how that feels
let petit Virizion
is this one of Sarah Hawkins paintings
I didn't look at everything
[Music]
what is that I want to look at this the
picture
and won't let me go back into that state
now
okay I guess I'm trying to get back into
that state so I can see everything else
but it's not letting me so I still what
do you know why I prompted me to get out
of it before I even found everything but
oh well again and whoever it is has
something to tell me about the Hawkins
dance
yo don't move the Hawkins case has been
wound up let the dead rest in peace I
was told I could be in here um I'm not
gonna threaten let's team up listen
that's clearly not new the victims
I'm sorry to dig up bad memories I can
still see the poor child lying burn on
the floor that drawing room he had to
tear him off the marks must still be
dared there in my mind anyway it's
horrendous I'm going to need your
experience to bring him justice mr.
Brett can you explain what this painting
is doing this strange portrait wait I
know it it was in the Hawkins mansion
when we came to investigate the fire so
you confirmed that it was removed from
the crime scene I'd like to go and see
the mansion of course you want to go
back along his trail
I'd like to understand how this painting
made it to here come on
my car's parked down the way well it's
probably cat right she's sitting on the
husband when your eyes damn it this guy
went right under your nose no can't let
me in
god damn it her again
this case has nothing to do with you pay
care clear the passage or I'll shut you
up for obstruction
officer Bradley you finally grown a pair
too bad you're too fat to see them down
there why are you come out keep the
smile you don't want to force me to
widen it okay I get it
can we go to the mansion now I thought
I'd straightened you out mister I am
disappointed but we'll meet again
is it far what does she do this
straighten him out kick him in the balls
as well look behind you at the top of
the ridge
you see the building
that's the hulking match come on very
safely stowed sweet so what do you guys
think of the game so far I'm gonna have
to leave because I have to have dinner
and stuff but what do you think of it so
far it's not scary yet and but I'm
thinking it's gonna get more scary more
scarier as time goes on so yeah I'm
hoping to like stream this more if not
tomorrow then very very soon but
obviously tomorrow is Halloween and I
might be doing stuff I might not I don't
know like my plans are all up in the air
at the moment but follow me on Twitter
and you will find out when I am
streaming next it's not tomorrow it'll
be at some time very soon but yeah
thanks so much for watching me play and
watch them the first impression sorry it
took me so long I just really did not
want to make that deal with Kat but I
had to so we'll find out what the future
how that pans out anyway um yeah so give
me a will they all follow on Twitter and
you can find out where I'm streaming
next
[Music]
and I will see you wait should we just
watch the next cutscene anyway if it is
a cutscene yeah sure why not that's
that's watch the cutscene the place seem
to be around oblivious to surprises
signs of recent occupation as well as a
partly charred painting interrupted and
his section but officer Bradley Pierce
convinced him to join his investigation
so I wonder what would have happened if
we went to like when to hurt him instead
that would have been pretty interesting
those trades are so dramatic oh wait
wait someone's watching us
well here we are hawkins mansion
the place is being abandoned since the
fire there's only old Winchester in his
hut Winchester okay fine we'll just talk
to him quickly
I see no sports trees or fire down the
DOMA building you're pretty damn
observant ain't you well I am old Silas
acted as soon as he could not soon
enough to save the halkans they were
trapped in the drawing room and don't go
troubling Silas anymore
his guilt torments him enough as it is
are we gonna take a closer look at this
mansion or do you have other questions I
have more questions answer my questions
[Music]
your partner Andrews warned me against
him you managed to get something out of
that bomb I'll end up asking you for
advice he talks too much he inferred
that old Silas was slightly unhinged
that's not far off the mark I suppose
but kinda unfair at the same time you
know Silas Winchester has been working
for the Hawkins family as far back as I
can remember
Charles was like a son to him day of the
fire he lost his whole family so he's
got nowhere to go
and as you'll see in a way he's still
watching over them is there anything
else you want to ask me or do you want
to go up there I'm still asking um
you're the one who looked after the
Hawkins case don't think I was trying to
hide it it's just that this discovery
shakes my convictions that's why you're
so keen to find out who removed the
painting from the mansion yes if
something escaped that's all if there's
been a law-enforcement error then it's
up to the police to make good it's
mistake anything else
I've heard this is going to be trouble
so wise attitude but apart from old
Silas and some rotten floorboards
there's nothing to worry about
could he be a problem strictly speaking
he ain't dangerous but since the tragedy
he's been a little touched though he's a
remarkably sturdy man given his age a
true force of nature a sad old man
doesn't worry me she if you don't want
to listen to my advice we might as well
go right sure you have you have yeah
this is you won't get me to believe that
it looked any better three months ago
it's a very old building you know its
foundations would probably date from the
arrival of the first settlers it's got
nothing to do with Charles Hawkins debts
you've already become the nose around it
would seem I'm an adult since he won't
really know it the Hawkins family
couldn't afford the upkeep of this house
it remains to be seen what they did with
all their money
I wager it was Charles Hawkins travels
let's go up there
unless you still have questions troubles
or drinking hmm okay night falls quickly
here and I want to be able to see when
we arrive I'll go it's already nice only
to reissue asylums
one of why not you can help right let's
go okay this is where I leave you
right so what you've what you've all
gone again
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoy do let me know what you think
about this so far it seems like this
game it's probably gonna take just like
a little bit of getting used to a little
bit of getting into it's very story
driven I like how this seemed to be
quite a few different choices already
but it's so annoying that it's kind of
down to your personality traits but hey
that's kind of like how it isn't real
life anyway right so I wasn't strong
enough to open the hatch therefore I had
to go with cats and now I'm in debt
great not one that to have it oh well
but yeah thanks so much for watching
um goodbye exotic nephilim goodbye
Adonis goodbye Alex goodbye Jacob Ike
bad behavior goodbye thou art Reaper
goodbye mister maestro and don't forget
to follow me on Twitter to find out when
the next string will be I also have a
video that is ready to come out on the
1st which is Thursday
yeah tomorrow is Halloween so look out
for that I hope you enjoy that party in
1930s America alcohol really once the
source of everything this is what Alex
says during the time the government had
laws that banned alcohol from all public
places how would that make sense that
makes that makes a lot of sense so
that's why she's running the place
because she's the only one that can get
the alcohol in the place you shouldn't
really be drinking it so just make a lot
of sense
oh and thanks for saying they look like
that I'm doing well
mr. maestro I hope you guys are doing
well too and naked snake thank you for
coming thank you for your input
hello there but if we're about to leave
so goodbye but welcome and please stay
around for the next streams yeah see you
later it's always awkward say goodbye
it's now I'm just like this bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye